[Music]
so for the past few years on this
platform youtuber nando v movies has
helped organize creators around
analyzing single scenes from movies
they've done it with one marvelous scene
one excellent scene and one villainous
scene this year i thought i'd
participate so
what do we have going to be looking at
something different something that
almost all scenes have in common
music this is one
musical scene
huh
all right then i kind of scrambled
wondering if i even had much to say on
this kind of topic i don't have much in
the way of musical training i wouldn't
be able to break down a piece of music
with much expertise however
as i perused my movie collection to see
if anything sparked interest my brain
really started to latch on to this idea
the question then becomes
what to go for for a really standout
musical scene i considered some obvious
candidates like 10 things i hate about
you guardians of the galaxy volumes one
or two i even considered
there were some more off the beaten path
options that could have been fun like
desperado highlander or monty python's
the meaning of life but because my movie
was arranged alphabetically it wasn't
until i got near the bottom that the
obvious choice hit me in the face
because my friends
she's not bad
she's just drawn that way
[Music]
whoa hold on nope nope we cannot just
jump to the start where the music kicks
in we need some context for the build-up
because that's part of what makes this
scene
so dang good now don't worry i'm not
about to recount the plot of who framed
roger rabbit up until that point but
there is some important stuff that
should be there now the film set in 1947
and it posits a world in which humans
cohabitate with tunes and it focuses
this whole story through the lens of
hardened private eye eddie valiant he
doesn't like tunes for reasons the film
gets into later but the fact that he
doesn't like them is established right
off and for the scene that we're getting
into that's really all we need to know
eddie gets hired by one rk maroon the
head of a toon studio and he's hired to
look into one of its stars roger rabbit
or more accurately to look into roger's
wife jessica since maroon suspects that
marital problems might be at the root of
why roger can't focus on work he keeps
blowing his lines
this sends eddie to the ink and paint
club a club where tunes perform live and
also make up the bulk of the staff but
also aren't allowed in as customers
mirroring how black performers were
treated around the same time as eddie
enters animation icons daffy duck and
donald duck no relation i don't think
they're doing a dueling piano's number
that eventually descends into absolute
chaos as eddie takes a seat right in
front of the stage
this was actually already a pretty big
play for the film the movie established
very early on that there was going to be
a mix of tunes but really the only ones
to get a focus were roger and his
co-star baby herman and most of what
we've seen otherwise we're in the
background with just a couple of quick
highlights of disney characters
but this meeting of two legends of
animation from rival studios takes the
entire thing up a notch and honestly
it could have been a fatal blow to this
scene because how do you top that
well
you bring down the music
eventually cut out all the sound and
then
you do this
[Music]
exaggerated proportions aren't exactly
without president because there were
cartoons like little hot red riding hood
back in the day but by and large
audiences hadn't seen a character quite
like this and stunning as her look is
the music and the song does
so much to enhance an already amazing
scene like seriously can you even think
about the scene without hearing the
music in your head
[Music]
so let's break it down a little bit
the song being sung here is why don't
you do right which has been around since
1936 with the best known version being
performed by peggy lee the song has
always been playful a bit flirty but
this rendition slows it down and lets
vocalist amy irving go full sultry
why don't you do right
[Music]
and right off the bat there's a notable
difference between this and other
versions of the song
every other version that i could find
has a musical intro peggy lee lil green
julie london ella fitzgerald
they all start with the instruments
first then the singer comes in the band
sets the tone for the singer to then
continue
here
there isn't the slightest hint of music
before we get jessica's voice
[Music]
well also her leg and her bust but
we're focusing on the voice right now
this is actually really important for
jessica's character her place in the
story and her impact on me
as a young viewer
she starts the number she sets the tone
she
is the one
in control
and that more than anything
is what the music and this song brings
across because let's be honest it would
have been so easy for this to only be
about how beautiful she is how hot guys
think she is how strange it is that
she's married to roger of all people and
all of that is present but
this is really about how much power she
holds a point made more explicit as she
works through her number
tormenting the men along the stage
before singling out our hero and making
it clear that whatever happens
is on
her say-so
and no one else's
one of the effects of slowing the pace
of the song down is that it goes from a
kind of medium jazz tempo to something
closer to the kind of music that usually
accompanies a femme fatale in a noir
film
which was quite well ingrained into pop
culture and was already being frequently
parodied by the time this movie came out
she had a full set of curves
and the kind of legs you'd like to suck
on for a day
but again
here while it evokes that it's not just
background music setting the scene for
the audience it's a song that jessica is
singing and that means that the musical
links to the archetype of the femme
fatale isn't something that the film is
placing on her it's something that she
has chosen that she is allowing and that
she
is in
control of
i hinted that this scene had a pretty
big impact on me and in my young days
there were a few things over the years
that
kind of latched into my head and in
hindsight make me wonder why i thought i
wasn't trans for as long as i did but um
i've said in the past i don't
really have a single clear light bulb
moment in any of my memories that where
i suddenly saw something went i want
that i want to be feminine and i stand
by not having that kind of moment i did
however have a number of smaller moments
that added up over time and the entrance
of jessica rabbit was definitely one of
them
i was fascinated by her
you need to realize
at the time this movie came out and when
i saw it i was pre-puberty so i wasn't
engaging on it on an ogling level but i
was bowled over by her power though i
wouldn't have been able to explain it in
those words at the time but she walked
in
leading with her voice and without even
a moment of doubt was clearly in control
of everyone in that room i'd honestly
say there are few characters of any
gender who are able to establish power
so quickly and plainly than jessica does
with a leg a breast and the first
sentence of a song
everything in the scene comes together
her design her angles the silence that
leads up to her entrance the act the of
the preceding performance being such
high-energy cartoon antics making the
mood of her number stand out all the
more bob hoskins absolutely nailing the
look of a man completely bottled over by
something he wasn't ready for
and this one
last act of dominance mirroring the
start of the song by giving us silence
and then jessica alone allowing the
scene to continue
[Music]
an amazing movie an iconic character and
one musical scene
brings it all together
if you enjoyed this you'll find a link
in the playlist to all of the videos in
the one musical scene project down in
the description and i hope you'll check
those out
if you're new here consider hitting the
like or the subscribe or the commenty
boxy thingy uh this channel is made
possible by the support of my patrons
some of whom i'll be thinking in a
minute but whether you're new to the
channel or a longtime supporter tune
or human
what i want you to remember
is that you're beautiful
you're valid
and you are loved
you are the council
i'm just running the meetings
and sometimes i get to talk
about really amazing moments
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
time to give my thanks to my highest
supporting patrons that would include
robin moore zubin lutfullah tarak the
thing that goes doink in the anime
oliver b melinda walters imudelkey
theotha boyd becky sparks for knobby
likes the poodle zach idalin tracy
scrabbit angry casper adam rdl taylor
shane ross shaylee gourley brendan
larose and tt
[Music]
if you want your name said while these
guys try and distract me consider
looking at the rewards of my patreon
[Music]
um
[Music]